The simplest way that a LAN can be connected
is with something called a hub. Hubs are the
simplest form of interconnection and in some sense they
don't even exist in networks anymore today, because you can
build a switch for essentially the same price. But
for the sake of example, let's just take a
look at how a LAN would be connected with
a Hub. Now, a hub essentially creates a broadcast medium.
Among all of the connected hosts where all packets
on the network are seen everywhere. So if a particular
host sends a frame that's destined for some other
host on the LAN, then a hub will simply broadcast
that frame that it receives on an incoming port
out every outgoing port. So all packets are seen everywhere.
There is a lot of flooding and there are
many chances for collision. The chance of collision of course,
introduces additional latency in the network because collisions require
other hosts or senders to back off and not
send as soon as they see the other senders
trying to send at the same time. LANs that
are connected with hubs are also vulnerable to failures
or misconfiguration. Because even one misconfigured device can cause
problems for every other device on the LAN. Suppose
that you had a misconfigured device that was sending
a lot of rogue or unwanted traffic. Well, on a
network that's connected with hubs, every other host on the network
would see that unwanted traffic. So, we need a way to
improve on this broadcast medium by imposing some amount of isolation.